[Music]
on this friday night extradition for a
former fashion executive
some vindication for the alleged victims
of peter nygaard i want people to see
who he really is
and what a monster he is the new series
of charges he's facing prime minister
trudeau's trip on the first truth and
reconciliation day triggers trouble he
doesn't care about our rights alberta's
doctors and nurses struggling under the
crush of covet 19.
you feel like you're drowning what's
holding up the help from the feds
and the eye of a storm no ship wants to
be inside a hurricane unprecedented
footage from within one of the earth's
most violent phenomena
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight bara nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us disgraced former canadian fashion
mogul peter nygaard is facing new
charges in canada multiple accounts of
sexual assaults and forcible confinement
the 80 year old appeared in a winnipeg
court today via video link on the slew
of american charges he's facing and his
extradition hearing was live streamed
cameras are rarely allowed inside
canadian courtrooms and for nygard's
alleged victims it was a bittersweet
moment
i see a weak
frail old man um
who
is also a monster um
you know hearing his voice brought back
a lot from me um
it it brought me back 23 years ago
yeah
it's amazing that all of that time has
passed but it can bring you back to that
moment
where you were terrified
global's brittany greenslade conducted
that interview and she's been following
the case since nygard's arrest last year
she joins me now brittany
farah this was the public's first look
at peter nygaard inside a winnipeg jail
cell and the first time since his arrest
on sex trafficking charges we've heard
him speak
order committal on the single charge and
the authority to proceed
namely trafficking in persons is that
correct mr nygard that's good that's
correct yes
so you understand the significance of
this document that you sign standard
yes i do peter nygaard is no longer
fighting extradition to the united
states his legal team is trying to speed
that process up perhaps that's because
while nygard faces nine counts in the
southern district of new york he's
consented only to be extradited for
trial on a single trafficking charge
there this whole process was about
him having a trial in the united states
and his
hope and ours is that he'll be
vindicated
that's the reason that
this process was expedited or it may
have more to do with the nine criminal
charges nygaard faces in toronto for
sexual assault and forcible confinement
nygaard has dozens of accusers who've
reported decades of abuse friday's
developments represent progress for some
with every step that's moving forward
in this case it does lift a little bit
of you know anger and sadness from me
just knowing that maybe there is just
but also reopen decades-old pain
every time
something comes around with this case
it's
reopening of 23 year old wounds renewed
criminal action against nygard has left
others feeling they no longer need to
remain silent toronto therapist shannon
maroney says she's supporting more than
40 alleged victims in canada and the u.s
who for years thought they were alone
and wouldn't be believed
so many have just said i am coming
forward now because i know i'm not alone
and
my story will support the stories my
experience will support the experiences
of my survivor sisters whoever they are
nygard's lawyers are hoping the
extradition process will conclude later
this year it'll be up to the federal
justice minister whether nygard must
face the canadian charges first brittany
greenslade global news winnipeg
nygaard is accused of using his
influence in the fashion industry to
lure women and girls he founded his
company in winnipeg in 1967 it grew from
a partial stake in a garment
manufacturer to a brand name sold in
stores around the world at one point it
was the largest producer of women's
clothing in canada nygard international
filed for bankruptcy last year
prime minister trudeau is taking heat
over how he spent canada's first
national day for truth and
reconciliation instead of attending one
of many events yesterday he was at a
beach in tofino b.c with his wife as
david aiken reports the decision has
angered and saddened many indigenous
leaders
we saw an outpouring of empathy and
compassion from across the country coast
to coast from canadians wearing orange
taking action and our prime minister was
missing an action anger disappointment
frustration from indigenous leaders we
were very shocked and very disappointed
and we don't understand how it's
possible that he
could not have taken the time to be
publicly present for such an important
day very disrespectful
and
you know it represents a slap in the
face to
the
families of residential school
victims residential schools
leaders of the first nation in kamloops
b.c had sent two invitations to trudeau
to join them at their ceremony thursday
trudeau has not visited the community
since burial sites were discovered on
the grounds of the former residential
school there i am truly saddened that he
was not able to join us today i did hold
out on hope that maybe that he would be
here
trudeau's plane a royal canadian air
force challenger left the national
capital at 7 am ottawa time and by 6 30
a.m pacific time he was within a couple
of hundred kilometers of kamloops where
the ceremonies would begin at 9 00 a.m
but he flew right over landing at tofino
shortly after 10 a.m local time why not
in person sir
trudeau and his wife are then seen
hiking the beach near the 18 million
dollar oceanside home that they have
rented it's a home dubbed surfer's
paradise
in a tweet late thursday trudeau
explained he did spend time on the phone
thursday talking to residential school
survivors his office said he spoke to
eight individuals but that explanation
was not completely satisfactory for
political critics like newly elected
metis mp blake desjarlais and i'll give
justin trudeau the benefit of the doubt
maybe he was reflecting listening while
on the beaches of tofino but i just
greatly feel as though many folks don't
and it sends the wrong message
and now pharah some indigenous leaders
are calling on the prime minister to
issue a formal apology for his trip to
tofino
david aiken in ottawa thank you david
to the pandemic now the federal
government says help is on the way for
alberta and resources are on standby for
saskatchewan if they're requested
alberta's been dealing with more than a
thousand new cases a day for weeks and
icu awards are almost twice their
capacity the canadian armed forces and
the red cross are sending medical staff
to help overwhelmed hospitals but as
jamie morocco reports there's no word on
when that help will arrive
riding his bike provides a rare quiet
moment these days for edmonton-based icu
doctor daryn markland you're working so
hard that you feel like you're drowning
and that is only because of the need to
manage our resources now exhausted
resources and workers icu's in alberta
are bursting at the seams operating in
emergency mode the federal government
has been offering to help for weeks
finally premier jason kenney accepted
but it will take time to get human
resources and skilled workers there it
depends on the details from alberta we
we are waiting to hear who they need and
where and what kinds of professionals
and right now there is no time to waste
in alberta and saskatchewan we really
need a all hands on deck approach need
to have public health strategies that
impact everyone unfortunately right now
so that we can bring the numbers down
the president of the canadian medical
association is calling for a lockdown
and she isn't alone canada's top doctor
says without vaccines coupled with new
restrictions modeling shows cases will
continue to climb and critical care
units will overflow you have to reapply
some public health measures
because that's the fastest way to
suppress the transmission by reducing
contacts
while the vaccine coverage is
being elevated premier kenny has
squashed any rumors of lockdowns in
alberta and there's no word on
restrictions in saskatchewan two
provinces that alone make up 42 percent
of the country's icu cases our standard
of care is dropping there is no way that
we can keep the accelerated matted to
the floor for this long and not blow the
engine out a once avoidable crash the
entire country is watching as it happens
jamie morocco global news toronto
there's only one province without a
vaccine mandate for health care workers
and even that may be changing the
newfoundland and labrador government is
in talks with unions and a mandate could
be announced next week employees who
choose not to be vaccinated in ontario
pei new brunswick manitoba and
saskatchewan can opt to be tested
regularly instead those who refuse to
get vaccinated in quebec nova scotia
alberta and b.c can be suspended or put
on unpaid leave
there are two sides to this debate but
as mike armstrong reports both agree on
one thing losing staff will have an
impact
after 18 months of strain quebec's
health care system may be looking at a
little more just around the corner the
clock is ticking down to the october
15th deadline for health care workers to
be vaccinated and some are warning that
mandate won't come without a cost
our biggest worry right now is that we
won't have enough staff to give proper
care to the population
christina hoares with the nurses union
she represents about 3 400 nurses in the
regional health board that covers
montreal's west island right now horse
says about 7 percent of her members
aren't vaccinated but that in the middle
of a pandemic they can't afford to lose
them right now with those seven percent
on the floor we're missing staff at a
critical level so removing seven percent
more
is just going to make things a whole lot
worse they will not
be able to to work quebec's health
minister says the province isn't
changing its mind because san diego says
about 16 000 health care workers still
aren't vaccinated but he says things are
going in the right direction three to
four hundred health care workers are
getting their first dose each day if
they get their first dose immediately
over the next few days
the penalty of not receiving their
salary will be limited now speed is one
of the criticisms out there some of the
health unions say they support the
vaccination mandate but that the
deadline was too quick they say it's
left members nervous the pressure
they're feeling is about to get worse
obviously that's a worry people have
been working at a
150 since a year and a half now it will
have an impact but it's not going to be
like huge i mean dr gilbert boucher
represents emergency medicine
specialists he says contingencies are
already being made to work around the
people who will be missing but boucher
says the mandate is needed to protect
patients a vaccinated doctor or nurse
can still catch covet and be contagious
but much more so if they're unvaccinated
when we do testing on people i mean if
you're double vaccined you're infected
we detect a little bit of virus but if
you're not vaccinated it's millions and
millions of virion you're shooting
everywhere letters are going out right
now in quebec two unvaccinated health
care workers the health minister says
it's to make it clear the mandate is
happening and they're going to be
without a paycheck
soon
mike armstrong global news montreal
global news gets exclusive access inside
modernist facility coming up the drug
maker's mission to stay ahead of covid19
plus please to cut the red tape the
bureaucratic nightmare for afghan
refugees
a u.s drug maker has released data
showing its experimental coven-19 pill
reduced hospitalizations and deaths by
half in people recently infected with
the virus
merck says it will soon apply for
emergency use authorization in the
united states and around the world the
drug would be the first pill shown to be
effective against coven 19 and a major
advance in the fight against the
pandemic all currently approved
treatments need to be given as
injections of iv infusions
health experts say vaccines are still
the best way we can protect ourselves
from covid19 but the virus is changing
and pharmaceutical companies are trying
to keep up our carolyn jarvis recently
traveled to moderna's production hub
just outside of boston she got an
exclusive look at how the company is
keeping pace with the pandemic
to say moderna is growing by the minute
wouldn't be fast enough we're right now
in manufacturing
around a thousand employees
we have
doubled in about five months
and we're trying to hire about 500 more
as we speak right now its technology
center just outside of boston feels like
a headquarters from silicon valley they
refer to it as a campus with
neighborhoods
and this is where moderna's covered 19
vaccine was first made and that all
started right here all started right
here every step of making an mrna
vaccine is checked and rechecked this is
actually technology that's used by the
nfl to track performance of athletes a
receiver mounted on the ceiling tracks
operators through a sensor in their id
badge so employees who are assigned to
work in one drug product area each
meticulously color coded and taped off
don't cross over into another we will be
able to have an alarm that tells us that
they went a place they shouldn't go
wow yeah it's important while mederna
continues to supply vaccine around the
world it's also focusing on how the
virus is changing do you have teams of
people back there trying to forecast
where the next variant may occur oh
absolutely the moment there's the first
posting of a new sequence to the
international databases we download that
we look at all of the different
mutations that are merged and we ask
ourselves the question is this the
canary in the coal mine is this the one
that we're worried about moderna
currently has six different boosters in
development including one targeting the
delta variant delta
surprised us delta as a variant is far
more transmissible but fortunately delta
is not an immune escape variant and what
i mean by that it's not one that has
really hidden itself from our vaccines
or our immune systems the variant
moderna is most concerned about is one
we fortunately haven't seen yet an
immune escape variant which is highly
transmissible that could evade our
vaccines that one sequence that looks
like it combines all the mutations that
scare us the most will be the one that
we have to run towards as fast as
possible carolyn jarvis global news
boston
carolyn also speaks with some of
canada's leading scientists about how
the vaccines are holding up and why they
say it may not be time for a booster
just yet that's tomorrow at 7 when the
new reality returns for a new season
right here on global
still ahead the desperate calls for
canada to fast track help for afghans
waiting in danger
singers andrea day and andrea bocelli
were part of a big opening ceremony to
kick off the middle east's first world's
fair after a year's delay due to the
pandemic expo 2020 is now welcoming
visitors the six-month-long exhibition
features more than 190 countries
including canada a massive futuristic
landscape was created in what was not
too long ago
a barren desert
one month ago the taliban took full
control of kabul airport canadian
aircraft helped 3 700 people leave but
hundreds of canadian citizens or
permanent residents were left behind and
many thousands more vulnerable afghans
with links to canada are still inside
the country global news spoke to a
former canadian forces interpreter who
managed to get his canadian visa and
made it to pakistan with his family
like so many others he says he still
fears for those still in afghanistan
redmond shannon reports
hidden among the taliban-controlled
streets of kabul is a network of safe
houses now home to two thousand afghan
men women and children who had hoped to
get out of the country during the chaos
of august's airlifts they are some of
the country's most vulnerable and those
who worked with the canadian forces and
ngos the safe houses are funded by
donations organized by a canadian
veterans group veterans say just a few
hundred afghans have escaped into
pakistan since august with approvals to
go from there to canada
we faced many
problems on those days one of them is a
man we are calling marouf global news is
not revealing how he or others got to
pakistan only that the journey was
funded by the veterans charity marouf
alone knows 30 other families in hiding
in kabul desperately waiting to hear
from immigration refugees and
citizenship canada they are still
under threat
and they are scaring
and
they have
lost their minds right now
and they don't know what will happen and
still they are waiting for ircc
confirmation ledgers many don't even
have a reference number we have now
committed to welcoming 40 000 afghan
refugees to canada
veterans say that promise means little
if people don't have the documents and
the means to leave the pace we're moving
now it's going to be years before we
even get close to 40 000 people from
afghanistan in the country they want
ottawa to help facilitate and fund a way
out marouf says those in hiding are out
of money and options and they are just
waiting and waiting and which
kills somebody please speed up
their cases to get to islamabad to go to
canada or in from kabul to get to canada
because they don't have nothing right
now immigration refugees and citizenship
canada says it has approved applications
for more than nine thousand of thirteen
thousand applicants when it comes to
sending the visas you would only say it
continues to issue documentation redmond
shannon global news london
going where no drone has gone before
next forecast from the eye of a
hurricane
hurricanes are meteorological monsters
we know the damage they can cause can be
immense so understanding how these
storms intensify is crucial now in a
first of its kind scientific mission a
robotic surfboard was sent into the eye
of the storm mike drollet reports
nature can be fearsome we're not built
to withstand all it offers that makes
collecting data difficult and a new
robot designed to sail within a
hurricane
so very cool
canadian storm hunter mark robinson has
been close enough to nature to know the
sail drone can go where he can't we can
actually sort of follow the storm get it
inside storms that we wouldn't
necessarily be able to uh get uh you
know ships inside you know no ship wants
to be inside a hurricane the company
that builds a sail drone says this is
the first ever video from inside a
hurricane taken from an untethered boat
it recorded 15 meter high waves and 150
kilometer per hour gusts all the while
taking scientific readings that should
increase the accuracy of hurricane
tracking models
[Music]
because with weather every little bit of
data helps meteorologists use satellites
to see hurricanes from up high sensors
drop from planes to measure wind speeds
in the middle but the view from below
has never been accurate we think it's
part of the missing piece of the puzzle
of figuring out how hurricanes work and
and the reason why is we haven't had
continuous measurements within strong
hurricanes this might seem like a new
toy for meteorologists but if it helps
improve hurricane tracking accuracy
that's good for everyone
mike truly global news toronto
and that is global national for this
friday i'm farah nasser thank you so
much for spending part of your evening
with us tonight's year canada is chikaku
lake west of edmonton take care of
yourselves and each other
[Music]